what's hp lovecraft's favorite streaming
service
chatulu and we're already off to a bad
start
but let's begin as we mean to go on the
first episode of lovecraft country has
just dropped on hbo
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down everything that you
need to know about it
there's a lot to talk about so i just
want to dive straight into the episode
but obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything ruined then i recommend that
you take
the other road out of here if you're
still here then welcome to the heavy
spoiler show
i'm your host definition now let's get
into the breakdown
okay so lovecraft country begins in 1954
and similar to the book we follow a
korean war vet known as atticus
as he searches for his father in the
original work
atticus was called atticus turner but
here he's been renamed to atticus
freeman
to signify the subtext of the show which
is of course about racial tension
the show actually opens with a really
stylish introduction
in which he dreams about the war and his
time in the trenches
it's initially shot in black and white
potentially to symbolize how races often
fight alongside each other in battles
and color is not really seen by soldiers
however this
opens up the longer that the intro goes
on and i think it carries
a lot of symbolism with it now one of
the great criticisms of the vietnam war
by muhammad ali
was that he would be fighting against
another country for a country that
didn't really respect
or even like his race he found this to
be very hypocritical
and it's something that we see atticus
and the characters deal with
even though atticus fought for america
against the koreans
the people from his homeland view him as
less than they are and this really adds
a lot of tension
as we get further into the episode now
in the introduction we also hear a voice
narrate
this is the story of a boy and his dream
but more than that
it is the story of an american boy and a
dream that is truly american
now this is actually a quote from jackie
robinson who was the first
african american to play major league
baseball it's at this point that things
take a big turn
and some war of the worlds inspired
aliens dropped down
and two take part in the conflict a
red-skinned alien descends
before chitulu appears and is then taken
out by jackie robinson himself
we then cut to atticus on a bus and we
can see that he's reading the princess
of mars
like atticus says this is a story about
an ex-confederate soldier aka john
carter
who ends up going to mars and fighting a
war there i actually think that this
symbolizes the subtext of the story too
and how the season will go on the whole
point of the book was to show that black
people can be heroes
and the stories that we know and love in
the early 20th century
african americans were not really
featured in fiction
due to white writers not including them
however lovecraft country is
retroactively going back
and allowing them to be part of fiction
during the time this is why the book
and likely season features a wealth of
sci-fi
horror and adventure storylines now i
have read the book and it does get
pretty wild
so do expect a mix of genres the further
that we get into it
unfortunately the bus breaks down and
the driver shows up with alternate
travel
however atticus decides to skip the ride
and he walks home with another black
passenger after getting a couple of
funny looks from the truck owner
atticus informs the woman that he
received a strange letter from his
father montrose
and we then jump to chicago here we meet
atticus's uncle george
and his wife hippolyta who end up having
a bit of
a bit of afternoon delight they
discussed the book they're working on
which is called the safe negro travel
guide this features heavily in the
original source material
and it basically works as a guide for
african americans to avoid towns
and locales that might be dangerous now
this was actually a real text
which was published in 1936 and it ran
all the way up to 1966.
in lovecraft country it also provides
some warnings on the monsters
but we'll get into that later in the
video we also meet diana
and with atticus the group have a
reunion before the latter travels out to
the guide office
here he picks up the book the outsider
and the others by lovecraft
which is published by arkham house
arkham is later dropped as a name
and this is actually a publishing body
that kept lovecraft's work alive
long after his death with george atticus
also discusses herbert west reanimator
before dropping the name lovecraft
country the pair talk about atticus's
missing father
and he reveals the content of a letter
that was sent to him in this
montrose detailed a secret ancestor and
the birthright that had a kiss was owed
i'll talk about this later in the video
after dropping a big spoiler warning
because
it does ruin a certain part of the book
if you've not read it
but just be aware of this that ariser
does tie massively into the overall plot
now george corrects arkham to autumn and
atticus goes to denmark faces ball
looking for more information on his dad
this was actually named after denmark
vasey
who planned a slave rebellion in 1822
and was executed because of it
now we jump across to a knight block
party and here we meet letitia
played by journey smallit who just so
happens to be the sister of
juice moulay her older sister ruby
performs her sister rosetta
song on stage and we learn that her
brother is near a town called bideford
in england bideford was the location of
a witch trial in 1682
and as witches actually feature in the
source material
it does hint towards what could be
coming down the line we also get a tease
of letitia's character here
as we discover she only showed up to see
her sister because she needed a place to
stay
throughout the work letty initially only
really goes to people because she wants
or needs something
she acts nice to them and uses her charm
to lower their god
but overall her friendship often has
ulterior motives
we then see atticus and george looking
over a map of the country
with several symbols indicating what's
included in the areas this ranges from
werewolves to wizards
and even clan members the latter two
become interlinked the further that we
get into the story
and the conversation culminates with
atticus realizing that his father is
located in the land of death
atticus then goes back to his home and
here he finds the count of monte cristo
novel
this centers around a count who's
wrongfully imprisoned and he then
escapes his confines and amasses a
fortune
before bringing revenge to those that
wronged him this could be a metaphor for
what will happen later in the storyline
when atticus himself is taken captive
atticus also comes across his father's
gun
and speaks to gi who just so happens to
be the same actress that played the
red-skinned alien woman that we saw in
the introduction
atticus awakens to find letty trying to
hit your ride and though they don't say
it
you can tell the two go way back the
road trip really brings them together
and along with george the three head out
across the country in search of
atticus's dead
across the midwest they pass an ice
cream stand in which we see a family
waiting to be served at the coloured
stand
whilst the staff members ignore them and
chat away they also pass a sign that
warns african americans
to not let the sun set on them in the
area this is because they've entered a
sun downtown
which ties into the title of the episode
itself sundown towns were places where
white people allowed black people to
venture around during the day
but at night they viewed it as a civic
duty to arrest them
and sometimes even kill them this is
later referred to by policemen
and it becomes the tensest part of the
episode now people at a pit stop make
monkey noises towards atticus
and we see the juxtaposition of this as
the group are ostracized
out of the area whilst drawings of their
faces are also used to advertise
things such as ancient this really shows
the differences between societies
and other monsters are used as a
metaphor we really get the idea that
there is a dichotomy of society here
this is showcased in a queue of african
americans waiting for the bus
whilst a picture of a white family
driving a car hangs above them
it's not too subtle but the montage
shows you how things really were back
then
and how african americans have had to
deal with several indignities
the group dropped by the simmonsville
diner which is recommended to them by
george
inside though they discover that it's
now under white ownership
we learned that the previous owners were
run out of the town and is possible that
it could have been burned down
due to the walls being white this is
similar to how the white house was
painted wide after it was badly burned
and a floor tile at slides gives it all
away
letty catches a member of staff calling
the owners and she rushes out to warn
the pair
but it's too late as a group of firemen
and citizens arrive
chasing the trio whilst firing guns
luckily a silver car shows up to save
them
and this is tied to atticus as it was
seen following him
earlier in the episode a mysterious
woman steps out
and i believe that this is christina
breithwight
she's someone that is tied to atticus's
legacy i think she's gonna become a big
villain in the season
they make it to lady's brother marvin
who tells them of bideford
and they also discuss the local sheriff
who pretty much enforces the sundown law
the sheriff becomes the big bad of the
entry and it's definitely important that
you pay attention to him here
marvin and letty end up fighting as
things from the past are brought to the
present
and it's here that we get hints about
letty's true intentions and how
she drifts from person to person getting
what she wants
but she doesn't really have any
stability atticus and george
too have their disagreements over their
father and brother
clearly there's tension between the pair
over atticus joining the army to fight
for a country that hates him
and this caused a lot of anger between
him and his father montrose
the next day is when things really start
to heat up
and the group make their way to autumn
however they become lost in the woods
and pull over to figure out what to do
now if you've read the book
then you'll know that this is one of the
most gripping parts of it
i always wondered how this would
translate to screen and it
really doesn't disappoint here sheriff
hunt arrives
and the actor perfectly nails delivering
lines that are deeply chilling
while smiling through great teeth i love
how he gives them a time limit
and then stalls them as much as possible
so that they have less and less of it
he drops the line about the entire
country being a sundown one
and stalks them as they try to make
their way out of the area
now not only are they not allowed to
speed but they're also forced to take a
specific road
and this leads to an incredible seed
that's also
the slowest car chase i've ever seen but
also
one of the tensest now before he arrives
there is mention of a shoggoth
and this is actually a monster from
lovecraft's chittulu mythology
like atticus says it's basically a blob
with eyes and teeth
but it's not the real monster here that
is the sheriff
now this is what lovecraft country does
brilliantly and normally in horror films
when there's a monster you breathe a
sigh of relief when the police show up
however
here it's the other way around and
you're actually relieved when a monster
shows up to take down the police
the group make it across the county line
but they're stopped by a blockade of
deputies and taken through the woods
here they're accused of committing a
spate of burglaries and just before hunt
executes them for knowing his name
we hear the cries of the shoghorth now
if i was a policeman
i wouldn't be going into any of these
woods at all ever
and we can see why because it completely
decimates their forces
whilst letting atticus take shelter in a
cabin
hunt and another policeman make it to
here too and hold out whilst george
runs across the forest george actually
survives
and he draws the conclusion that the
creatures fear light and he quotes
dracula before they formulate a plan
letty is forced by hunt to make a run
for the car and the shoghoth stalks her
and it just makes me scream run forest
run
in the cabin the bite slowly transforms
hunt into one of the creatures
and he begins to mutate before tearing
the other officer apart
lettie makes it to the car and hits hunt
with it but he flees off into the night
likely to make a return down the line
the trio leave the cabin which is when
they shoggoth surround them
and it looks like their time is up but a
mysterious whistle
summons them away the group survive and
they make their way to autumn
which is when they arrive at a mansion
here they spot a silver car
and are greeted by caleb braithwight
which ends the entry
now what's going on what what the hell
is going on
well we will be discussing some book
spoilers so if you don't want to know
anything then i recommend that you turn
off now
now it is revealed that caleb and his
sister are members of a group of wizards
known as the sons of adam it turns out
that atticus is the ancestor of their
leader
who had a child with a slave woman caleb
their leader wishes to perform a ritual
sacrifice on atticus
which will empower the group and this is
why he and his sister have led them here
all whilst protecting them i think the
next episode we will find out this
and also learn about their plan i don't
want to skip too far ahead and give you
the outcome of that as
you know you want some surprises but
that's who the character is
just in case you're wondering anyway
that's the first episode
and i have to say i absolutely loved it
and obviously i want to hear your
thoughts on it so make sure you comment
below and let me know
if you want something else to watch then
check out our breakdown of agents of
shield
and don't forget to subscribe to the
channel as we go through lovecraft
country every single week
we're also giving away a free copy of
the avengers on any console of your
choice
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment on what you think of the show
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of august so make
sure you get involved
as i'd love to see you win if you want
to support the channel and get to see
content early then please consider
clicking the join button below
and you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy swirlers on twitter
anyway thank you for making it until the
end of the video i've been definition
you've been the best and hopefully i'll
see you next week take care
peace
you